Let's now take a look at virtual texturing.
And so let's first talk about what virtual texturing is.
So you can see how we have this option to enable virtual texture support, which you'll
sometimes see it used as RVT, which is runtime virtual texturing and streaming virtual texturing,
which is SVT.
So the runtime virtual texturing provides an efficient way to render complex procedure
generated or layered material.
So it makes runtime virtual texturing ideal for rendering complex materials and landscapes.
And it enables improved rendering performance and workflows for landscape splines, which
we'll cover in a little while here, decals for meshes and materials, along with general
landscape and object blending.
So the streaming virtual texturing reduces texture memory overhead when using very large
sizes, which includes support for virtual texturing lightmaps and UDIM, which is U-Dimension.
The streaming virtual textures is an alternate way to stream textures from disk compared
to existing MIP-based texture streaming.
And it follows what we'll do is we'll show how we can follow using runtime virtual texturing.
So if we enable the virtual texture support here by going to the rendering tab in your
project settings and go to virtual texturing and then click the enable virtual texturing
option, then we'll be able to make a new runtime virtual texture.
So once we've enabled that option, we can now go to a existing material that we want
to use virtual texturing.
So for this example, we've opened up the mat underscore virtual texturing underscore
start material.
So that's mat underscore virtual texturing underscore start material.
And now we can add a break material attributes node, which we discussed previously, and a
virtual texture feature switch, which you can see here as well.
So you want to connect the output of the base color layer blend node to the base color input
of the break material attribute nodes.
And then we also want to connect the normal, the layer blend to the normal input of the
break material attribute, and then also connect a scalar input with a value of 0.5 to the
roughness, which you can see here into the break material attributes node as well.
Then we can add a runtime virtual texture output node to the graph and then connect
the output of the base color to the layer blend to the base color input of the runtime
virtual texture output node, and then connect the output of the normal layer blend to the
normal input of the runtime virtual texture output node.
Then again, connect the 0.5 to the roughness input, add a constants node with a value of
1 and connect that to the opacity input, and then add a constants node with a value of
0 and connect that to the specular output.
Now we want to add a runtime virtual texture sample node and make a material attributes
node to the graph, connect the output on the runtime virtual texture sample to the respective
inputs on the make material attributes nodes, then connect the output of the make material
attributes node to the yes input of the virtual feature switch node.
Then when completed, your material should look like this image here.
Now we can add the runtime virtual texture volume to the level and then with the runtime
virtual texture volume selected, go to the transformation from bound section and set
the source actor to the landscape that is placed in the level.
So you just want to make sure you assign that landscape there and then press the copy rotation
and copy bounds buttons to make the volume as big as the landscape actor.
And then under the virtual texture input, select the virtual texture that was created
in our first step.
So just make sure you assign that virtual texture there.
Now select the landscape actor in the level and then in the details panel of the landscape,
go to the virtual texture section, press the plus icon and add a new input to the array
and then input the virtual texture that was created in the first step.
And then once all that has been completed, you should now see landscape material being
rendered in the viewport.
So you can see here the left hand side of the image shows that the landscape will look
like using non-virtual texture and then on the right hand side, we've got an image showing
what the landscape looks like using the virtual texture.
So if your landscape has black parts in it after the virtual texture, just try rebuilding
the landscape material, saving everything and then it should function correctly for
you.
We can also adjust the size of each of the tiles to make up the virtual texture.
So this can help if the textual density of the landscape is low.
To adjust this, all you need to do is open up the virtual texture and adjust the size
of the virtual texture in the tiles and then also the size of each virtual texture tile.
So keep in mind that when adjusting the virtual texture, the size has to be a power of two.
If in doubt, the tool will give you advice on what settings to use here.
And then we can also use virtual texturing with landscape splines.
So this is what it will look like when applied to a landscape spline.
Then you can bake it down into a landscape.
To make this work, you first have to add some splines to your landscape.
So you can do this by holding down control and left clicking on the landscape to create
a spline.
And then in the details panel, under the landscape spline, press the segments button to select
all the landscape splines.
And then if done correctly, you should now see a new option in the details panel called
landscape spline mesh.
If your landscape spline mesh is selected, press the plus icon to add the new static
mesh to the array.
And so for the mesh under the way using SM underscore street as a static mesh and then
uncheck center horizontally and change the forward axis to Y.
Finally, make sure to uncheck cast shadow.
And so the shadowing was done for more of an aesthetic reason.
Doesn't necessarily need to be done for this to work.
With the M underscore street material open, which is what was assigned to static mesh,
go to the material section and then the material now needs to be set up like we did the landscape.
So first make the material use material attributes, then bring the runtime virtual texturing output
and sample nodes, connect them like you can see in this image here.
And then you will end up with a result that looks something like this.
So you can see how we've got the normal spline on the left hand side and then also the virtual
texturing spline on the right hand side.